machine learning is becoming
increasingly important in the context of
mechanism design with many high impact
applications like
pricing and online marketplaces and
designing ad auctions and in this talk
i'm just going to give a very brief
overview of my research in mechanism
design in three areas
overfitting
incentives and privacy and i'll start
off with overfitting
so for those of you who are not
affiliated with the learning and games
seminar uh our workshop i thought i'd
just give a one slide overview of a
classic mechanism from mechanism design
this is an auction for selling a single
item and this is called the second price
or victory option with a reserve named
after nobel prize winner william vickery
so this is a mechanism parameterized by
a single parameter row
and you can think of row as a lower
bound on the amount that the seller is
willing to get for the item
so the first step is to collect a bid
from each agent who's participating in
this auction which is meant to represent
how much they value this item
next we give the item to the highest
bidder if they bid at least this
parameter row and we charge the winner
the maximum of row and the second
highest bid
and there are a lot of reasons why this
is a classic auction for mechanism
design maybe the most important of which
is that
given this kind of interesting pricing
role you can prove that the agents are
always incentivized to bid truthfully
there's nothing they can gain by being
strategic with their bid so it's called
the incentive compatible mechanism
and there are many other types of
parameterized mechanisms out there
beyond this one victory auction
so for example there are many types of
pricing mechanisms where you set prices
for the items and the agents come and
buy the items that maximize the utility
various other types of auction
mechanisms and even randomized
mechanisms like lotteries
so what made it look like if we were to
hope to design some these mechanisms or
tune these mechanisms parameters using
machine learning
well to answer this question i'm going
to make a standard assumption that has
been made for decades in economics which
is that the agent's values are drawn
from some distribution d
and we're going to assume that this
distribution is unknown
so the way that this mechanism
configuration procedure would look like
is first we fix some parameterized
mechanism family like the set of second
price options with that tunable
parameter row
next we receive a training set of agents
values drawn from this unknown
distribution d
and we perform some optimizations and we
find a parameter setting which has high
average empirical revenue over this
training set
and the question we want to answer
regarding overfitting is will that
parameter setting also lead to high
expected revenue on this unknown
distribution d or in other words will it
have high future revenue when we
actually go and field this mechanism
and these questions of overfitting have
been of significant interest
in um this economics and computer
science community over the past few
decades and i and many other people have
worked on on this question
and i wanted to tie it into my thesis
research more generally
uh which was more broadly about
algorithm design so to make this
connection
uh i want to think about a mechanism as
a special type of algorithm
where the input is a description of the
agent's values for the items for sale
and the output is an allocation of those
items and the payments required of the
agents so really a mechanism is just a
special type of algorithm with these
incentives issues that you have to take
care of
so in mechanism designed via machine
learning
the overall goal is to use data about
the agents to optimize the mechanism's
revenue
in my thesis research was more broadly
about algorithm designed by machine
learning so
using data about the particular
application domain which will be using
this algorithm
how can we optimize the algorithm's
performance so for example it's runtime
it's solution quality or in these
economic contexts it's revenue
this kind of auction design via machine
learning has been studied pretty
extensively from an applied perspective
in artificial intelligence over the past
two decades or so but this line of
inquiry was really kicked off from a
theoretical perspective by gupta and
ruff garden about five years ago
and we've thought about these topics of
using machine learning in the context of
algorithm design
for integer programming algorithms
computational biology algorithms
clustering and
routing and we have discovered over our
change structure linking these seemingly
disparate domains as well as mechanism
design which has allowed us to provide
very broadly applicable guarantees
okay so um now back to mechanism design
i want to give a high level overview of
what kind of questions i've thought
about in the context of incentives
so although in mechanism design we love
incentive compatible mechanisms many of
those mechanisms that are typically used
in practice are actually manipulable
so agents are able to
gain by
lying about their true values
this is true for example in ad auctions
and mechanisms for selling electricity
treasury bill auctions and increasingly
there's been an interest in designing
auctions using neural networks and these
the resulting auctions are typically not
incentive compatible
so in an ec 19 paper with nina balkan
and thomas sent home
we showed how to estimate how far a
manipulable mechanism is from being
incentive compatible
again using samples from this dish
unknown distribution over agents values
or more broadly over agents types
so using samples we show how to estimate
how
the mechanisms x and t approximate
incentive compatibility factor
and the key challenge in doing so is
that we must bound the amount of utility
the agent can gain by misreporting any
type over their entire type space just
using samples
and this is challenging because in these
mechanism design contexts the agent's
utility functions are have a ton of jump
discontinuities there are no notions of
lip shit's continuity or continuing
convexity that we're able to depend on
to provide these types of incentive
compatibility guarantees
okay and um now i'll conclude with a
couple of slides on my research related
to privacy and mechanism design by
machine learning
so these approaches using machine
learning for mechanism design typically
rely on a lot of sensitive information
including historical purchase data and
the training set
uniquely identifiable browser
information
and even browsing histories which are
often revealed to advertisers
so my research in the context of privacy
has looked at
how can we preserve the privacy of data
in the training set when we're doing
this type of mechanism designed by
machine learning
and more recently looking into the idea
of masking information about users which
you present to advertisers during ad
auctions
and i think this is a really interesting
and important area because as we've all
experienced over the past couple of
years
this need for data for the sake of
revenue maximization has caused
companies to develop some pretty
perverse incentives
addicting us to their platforms in order
to show us more ads and in order to
collect more data about us so i'd
especially really love to talk to people
and learn more about this area this
semester so that'll wrap up thank you
i should put it
oh
[Applause]
so